so Mojo is a programming language that
that allows you to do a higher level
programming the low level programming
like do all kinds of programming
in that spectrum that gets you closer
and closer to the hardware so take step
back so look what do you love about
python oh boy where do I begin
um what is love what do I love about
python you're a guy who knows love I
know this yes
um
how intuitive it is
how it feels like I'm writing natural
language English
uh
how when I can not just write but read
other people's code somehow I can
understand it faster it's more
and condensed than other languages like
ones I'm really familiar with like C
plus plus and C uh there's a bunch of
sexy little features yeah uh we'll
probably talk about some of them but
list comprehensions and stuff like this
and don't forget the entire ecosystem of
all the Packers oh yeah there's probably
huge there's always something if you
want to do anything there's always a
package yeah so it's not just
uh the ecosystem of the packages and the
ecosystem of the humans that do it that
that's a really
that's an interesting dynamic because I
think something
about the the usability and the
ecosystem makes the thing viral it grows
and then it's a virtuous cycle I think
well there's many things that went into
that like so I think that ml was very
good for Python and so I think that
tensorflow and Pi torsion these systems
embracing python really took and helped
python grow but I think that the major
thing underlying it is that Python's
like the universal connector right it
really helps bring together lots of
different systems so you can compose
them and build out larger systems
without having to understand how it
works but then what is the problem with
python
well I guess you could say several
things but probably that it's slow
I think that's usually what people
complain about right and so slow I mean
other people complain about tabs in
spaces versus curly braces or whatever
but I mean those people are just wrong
because it is actually just better to
use indentation
wow strong words so actually I have a
small tangent let's actually take that
let's take all kinds of tangents oh come
on Lex you can push me on I could take
mine and design listen I've recently
left emacs for vs code the kind of hate
mail I had to receive because on the way
to doing that I also said I've
considered Vim yep and uh chose not to
and went with vs code and just touching
on deep religions right